by setting up Vanda prototype to
delegate to car dot prototype failed
lookups on van instances like Amy will
fall all the way through to car dot
prototype when necessary to find methods
that are shared there another common
mistake is to try and make an object
that delegates directly to the
superclass constructor function itself
creating an object that delegates to car
instead of an object that delegates to
car dot prototype won't work because car
instances themselves are supposed to
delegate to car dot prototype this is an
example of a much larger problem that
you should be aware of people are
forever tempted to conflate the
constructor function and its companion
prototype object with the to serve very
different purposes perhaps the most
common mistake is attempting to
instantiate the superclass constructor
as a method of creating something that
delegates to its prototype this has a
nearly identical effect with the sole
exception that it runs the car function
in the process of creating this new
object which is undesirable the object
of create function is actually a rather
new language feature and before the
community knew too much about it common
practice prescribed setting van dot
prototype to equal a new car instance
but this causes a number of problems
notice that if we use this technique
every time we made a car subclass like
van or any other subclass of car we
would invoke car the function as part of
that process the superclass constructor
may also require some arguments as part
of its invocation like Lok but we don't
have any way of passing them in because
the new car prototype doesn't really
have a meaningful location the only
thing that has a meaningful location is
a car instance or a van instance the
abstract notion of all vans does not
have a meaningful location since there's
nothing useful we could pass in for the
Lok input variable the function will run
with all of its inputs being bound to
undefined imagine we were doing
something with those inputs like this
dot access what do you think would
happen in the case where we tried dot
access while having passed nothing in
particular in between the parens on new
car